my first rule even for myself is follow
you follow your heart so follow your
heart i i'm trying to follow mine and
trying to
to understand what it tells me at times
when it's not very clear
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders thank you for having me
so so fun to have you you know just
before we started the call
i discovered that you were a world
champion
bronze medalist in windsurfing that's
true it was when i was very very young
i'm
not actually practicing that anymore but
yeah
um and you were you were the israeli
national champion for quite some time as
well
yes yes unbelievable so first of all
let's start with that tell me what is it
like being a national champion of a
sport
and actually israel you know with with
the beach and the ways i mean a lot of
people surf so
it's not just like you know a random
sport that you picked up it's pretty
popular
and then what is it like going to the
world championship and actually you know
getting a medal
um that's an amazing uh feeling to to
get a medal and
to compete against uh world champions um
it was a great experience as a i was a
girl back then i was in high school and
then the army this is the times when i
was actually
uh doing that and uh just being among um
the team the israeli team which was i
was the only woman
still the only woman in everything i'm
currently doing
in many areas in my life but uh back
then i was the only woman in the
in the in the israelite game and you
know when we went to you know
competitions around the world i was kind
of sleeping with guys in the room
they were taking showers they didn't
even notice them i was actually a woman
they kind of
missed that so i was really part of uh
it was very unique time and uh i
actually think it really helps me today
because today i always find myself
also the the only woman in the room in
in most uh uh business environments um
i mean i t kind of so um i feel very
comfortable because i grew up this way
so
i'm already very very comfortable being
with you know
a room or or an ocean or a sea or
mediterranean's improvements
yeah so you're not just you know you're
not just an executive in a in a tech
company but you're actually executive in
a deep technology tech company
yahoo software and technologies i mean
it's it's leveraging artificial
intelligence and machine learning
to just to do some really fantastic
things and being an executive there and
and vice president of strategic
partnerships and alliances i mean you're
talking about
you know really understanding the
technology but also understanding the
the other people and the other in other
companies and i guess in a similar
industry which still today is still
unfortunately dominated by by male
counterparts right
yeah and is is that changing or is that
or is that sort of you know
the norm and and where do you see this
what do you see happening now in this
in this i see a change i see more more
women uh
not enough in leadership positions i see
them more kind of uh
you know coming up as developers and uh
program managers
you see more and more of them um and i'm
inviting more
women and girls and join of course
of course by the way talia i have to
tell you because i got so excited today
this is not relevant to our conversation
but i discovered coconut water
in the u.s today i never had it in my
life in israel and i'm obsessed with it
so
so these interviews i'm only drinking
coconut water it's really really good
coconut water it actually has a lot of
electrolytes and everything that you
need for your body if you work out and
everything it's really really good
when i went to burning man this is the
one thing i really packed my entire rv
was
with coconut water because i was told
that this is a good thing to have in
burning man when you kind of you're not
really taking care of your nutrition
wonderful wonderful wonderful okay so
you know right before we started
you know you're an expert on on building
alliances and relationships and what i
mentioned was that i like
talking about the things that the guest
or the leader is passionate about
and you immediately said i'm not
passionate about alliances i'm
passionate about people
tell me tell me tell me what that means
to you so alliances is a piece of paper
where you write like who's doing what
right so i'm not passionate about papers
and words
too much i'm more passionate about you
know i'm very privileged
to to to be doing day in and day out
what i love doing
and i meet people and i meet people from
different cultures and different
backgrounds i
work a lot with the india which is like
huge and and i just love it and people
in europe and and
nordics and israel and north america so
i work with all
cultures um and and i just love you know
the platform or the the agenda is the
business agenda
but just meeting people
meeting and understanding where they
come from what drives them
uh what beliefs they come from this is
what i'm really i'm very
i'm very fascinated about human beings
in general so
my work allows me to kind of explore
more
my area of passion which is people and
through that when you're really
interested when you're really
curious in people and what they're
looking for and what they want to get i
think it's a great way to really
accomplish
you know what you're also you know want
to do
you know for business like to get the
results to get the bottom line to get
revenues
because you can really build i really
care i really like
you know very very fast i built
relationship of trust with people
because
i really care and i really love you know
i love them i don't know
there's not no no other ways to say to
say that it may sound corny but uh no no
i think it's incredible
it's incredible and actually right as
we're having this discussion we're
talking about an internship program
for the fund that we're both involved
with jay ventures and and you know
going through the going through the
details and seeing how passionate you
are and you know
helping the the future generation and
how they are going to be integrated
within and learn from the fun and the
things that we're doing i think that
speaks exactly to what you're describing
here and i want to take you back a few
years
talk to me a little bit about how you
form these relationships
in the business setting so you know
these are not just friends they're
business friends that you're forming
alliances and relationships
my imagination and tell me if i'm wrong
is that you know two years ago or three
years ago you want to
form a business relationship you hop on
a plane you go over there you visit the
offices you go out to dinner
you go out to a broadway show and you
talk and you slowly build that trust is
that
is that fairly accurate i never took
anyone to a broadway show
but that's the whole point that's why
you do it no
no you don't have it's i i don't you
know i know that yeah
it's difficult to say that tells people
you will take your dine and wine you and
all this stuff i do that to some extent
but not really it's really like
the even through zoom you don't need to
take them to fancy places or
or anything just really speaking to
people and understanding where they come
from finding the common ground you
always have something in common with
another person
right really fast if you're curious
enough you'll find what it is and you
can build from there and then
you have the initial connection and once
you have that you learn more about each
other and we're all just humans even if
we come from different backgrounds there
is so much in common there is more
in common than not in common and just
you know you take down the barriers
and then you can you know when you have
trust and you have connection
you can build everything with it
anything with it so um
just human connection i don't know no no
i mean it sounds great but
now i want to take us to 2020 yeah
the the great 2020 that everybody likes
to say yeah
and you know we're in sort of the middle
of the year now or a little bit more
than the middle and
how do you build relationships i joined
a company a wonderful wonderful company
hippo insurance
i did my entire onboarding remotely i
didn't meet i met one person from my
team in person the rest are only through
video
how how how can i or how should i build
a meaningful relationship with my
colleagues
over over remote is that is it different
is it easier or harder
so this is not the only uh form of
communication yes so we use a lot of
zoom and you go on to video calls i
think it's
it's a very uh it's a great uh medium to
connect
deeply with people we see it like we
really look at each other when we
when the camera is on and not off and
people really look at each other in the
eyes
i think it's very very close i don't see
a lot of uh
difference um sometimes it's even an
advantage
when some when you where in a room of
people you know sometimes you know some
people
are not really related to the call or to
the meeting and
i i don't i i see disadvantage and
advantages to this medium
i don't find it harder to do business
overzoom than
um than i've done meeting face to face
and is that also true for meeting new
people or forming new relationships
so i understand the transition from
existing relationships continuing them
but is that the same case also for
finding new partners
and getting to that same level of
intimacy because you're missing a lot of
your senses right you're missing smell
touch you you're you're basically only
going based off it's a good thing to
miss the smell part
well i would assume that when you go and
build a business relationship then you
make an effort
no so so it's interesting because this
is really counterintuitive to
everything that i thought of what's
happening today first of all
i have a lot of new relationships that
i'm forming in the past uh
four months when you know i'm working
from home now and i'm not traveling
anywhere so i've been i've been forming
and
in the process of performing new
relationship with new companies with new
managed service providers as
large size and and it's going really
well i'm actually more efficient because
i'm sitting here all day
meeting after meeting i can do more in
the same amount of time i don't need to
travel around anywhere
and i can be very very focused on what
i'm doing and i have all my
things here and my notes like i'm very
very organized and i'm
i'm way more efficient so i'm i'm doing
so much more activities
um per day because i'm not traveling and
i don't have even
the office destructions and you know i
don't need to be nice to anyone around
me and
and have coffee with them during the day
i can just really focus on work which i
love doing and
i can do more and i can have one-on-ones
and when i start
relationship with somebody i'm also
connecting with them you know via
whatsapp and and
you know starting other forms and and we
are looking where we're we're
imagining the time you know the date
that we will actually you know be able
to
i'm going to have dinner with them or
something so hopefully that will come
soon no i i think i think it's
fascinating how it impacts so many
different facets of our of our work and
and i definitely see the upside and the
downside of
having this new sort of norm and take me
a little bit about what does it mean to
alliance building in terms of corporates
so
you know you're you're part of the big
organization that that
has you know i.t services what
why are lanes is important and what are
alliances actually in
in the tech world so it's really
important so
specifically in my company um the
alliance's part represent
over 60 of our revenues so i'm
responsible in my company for over 60
and and this is why it's so important it
really drives a lot of business
and it's way more efficient so we have
um in our company we have direct team
that is selling directly to the
enterprise and we have the partners team
which is my team
and we are selling through partners so
um and this part with less people we
sell much more
right so it's more efficient it's like
opening the doors to more strategic
long-term relationship versus just
selling
you know selling to one enterprise then
to another enterprise
when i form relationship with um with
our partners for example uh
the the global uh gsis of the world like
accenture deloitte
cognizant cup gemini uh just to name a
few
of the partners that i'm working with so
um when i form this
trusted relationship and we build the
right go to market plan together
that opens the door for my company to to
to get to 40 of their accounts so so in
one
informing one large alliances we can
actually sell
40 licenses versus one by one
so this this is the opportunity and this
is why it's so important and
and i really believe that today um in
you know in sas companies um any company
that is selling software today
uh partnership i i think it's already
it should be it will be a more integra
integral and
and and and big part of their their
business because
today it's all about the ecosystem the
air system you build it around you it's
like the isps the gsis
all the different partners that you're
strategically uh
engaging with um and it's a win-win it
helps them it helps us
it's all about working together and and
and having like synergetic type of
results out of that for both sides it
has to work for everyone
no no that that makes a lot of sense and
then do the relationships usually
occur between key people in both
organizations or is it
is it you know organization to
organization in other words you're
building a relationship now with another
organization
let's say deloitte and then you're
you're building it with you know key
people there that are you know agreeing
to this
let's say tomorrow they're advancing to
their next adventure
and how difficult is it to make that
transition of that transition of
alliance to another person because you
have to all of a sudden
build trust and relationship with
another person who has to decide whether
to renew this relationship to renew this
partnership right
so so when i'm building the relationship
so
first yes we're building it with key
people key people and key people so this
is kind of top
down right relationship but i'm also
even during the
cell cycle i'm taking care of the
bottom up as well so making sure that
their people are getting
certified and trained okay making sure i
create demands
um on the different uh pockets that
these on the business level but
kind of one layer two layers below
that are actually taking care of their
accounts so making sure they understand
the value and what it brings to their
clients
making sure they're they really um
building the incentives for them
to work with us so when you build it
with the top key people
and with the business level which is
like the medium director level that
really
uh manage accounts and you build it also
with the developers and operators and
delivery people and service people on
more than technical level enablement
type of things so you're building it in
all the levels in the right way
with a very uh uh defined go-to-market
plan
and kpis everybody are reliant around
kpis and you just manage this entire
process
then you know it's really you're getting
very very sticky it's really hard to
leave you and there it's actually no
reason to leave you
and if you also have their personal
relationship they will not just ditch
you for
you know some reason you can identify if
you if you have
an issue with anything and if there is
any competition that is threatening you
and
you can address it before no no of
course and you know when i
when i want to when i have an ambition
to be a software engineer at a company
i go and i study computer science i go
online and i and i teach myself how to
code in python or java or javascript
when you want to
be in alliances and partnerships um i
don't believe there's
a major for that i don't believe there's
an online textbook maybe there are
some you know self-help books on amazon
but but it sounds like you know
it's a lot of like practice on the on
the job and on the field
how do you prepare for a position like
that how do you even you know set
yourself up to go and and
become a vp of that at a company that's
an awesome question
i i think the greatest university for
the work that i do called life
so if you really um
and you know and and and for me
specifically this is really
an area that i love i i study like for
my own fun
on the side i study brain science and
consciousness
and spirituality and i have so much
interest in like human beings and
and how we use this box here in the top
of our
body called brain and how we can really
maximize it
and understand our beliefs and how it
drives us
so specifically for me i'm so interested
in this area called people and how
everything works in the universe all
together that
this is i think for me is that is the
best school because everything all the
books that i'm reading
the podcast that i'm listening to are
around those areas and i'm just
of course that really helps me in work i
have to say but you're already a vice
president
at a huge company how do you get to be a
vice president of partnerships and
alliances at a huge company
because you know you need that you need
that break to be able to go and learn
through life
how is it easy to get this break do you
join like
how where do you start in order to get
to that level
it's it's the opposite of taking break
of life to learn something it's the
opposite it's the more you are engaging
in life and the more you're busy so i'm
involved in many many things
i'm involved in gene ventures right and
now i'm helping you know putting
together the internship program
i mean and through everything i do and
i'm involved in high-powered women
and i'm involved in so many
organizations the more i'm
involved the more i have connections i
have an amazing roller decks i
i know a lot of people i have a great
network so that's access to just about
everything so every
anywhere i want to get to get to know
this person i can always get connected
by
somebody people will always help me i'm
always
my door is always open to helping others
and i'm always
my mission in life kind of is to really
help others grow
what in whatever they do so i think the
more you are
you don't need to take a break to learn
that actually the other way around be
engaged
speak with people network be fully in
in the game of life and that really
helps
those type of positions like business
development and alliances and then how
how knowledgeable do you have to be on
you know on the tech side of
things to really understand because at
the end you're you're sort of
selling a product you're not actually
selling you're finding you know you're
finding
ways to collaborate but then you have to
understand okay i'm selling
i'm not i'm not i'm not hiding from you
no no do you consider it selling
because often times because when i think
of alliances or partnerships i think of
you know a win-win situation for both
parties
well it's true but i'm i'm being i've
been compensated
for bottom line for revenues that i
actually bring to the to the company so
it's very very
measurable what i'm bringing like in in
and it's
it's on my paycheck i i can actually see
how it's going how i'm measured
so that's very much sales that's very
much aligned so um
how do you have people like get to that
uh the tech side um so i'm not a techie
i
i'm not an engineer i i learned you know
i'm just
learning everything i i feel when i have
a gap by just
asking or or learning or going on
youtube and
reading and understanding and i always
have like
not always but when you know it at some
point in the processes i
am bringing a more um an engineer to
actually
join me to those calls and and answer
the deep technical questions but on the
high level
i'm good enough you know to convey the
the benefits the business the business
outcomes and to even run through a demo
and and be a bit technical
to a degree not of course all the way so
it sounds like what you're saying is
that you know your strengths here are
your ability to really
you know to look at to look at others
understand their needs understand you
know both technologically but also you
know businessy
what does a yahoo software technologies
provide and then finding that
finding that you know a sweet spot of
collaboration where you can
you can provide the the services to them
and then along the process later on you
can provide that
engineering input which can do a much
deeper dive
which is not necessary when you're at
first in the high level of
what is this partnership that we're
gonna do perfect okay
okay wonderful tally what should i take
away from this as a young entrepreneur
as i go on my
on my next venture what do i what do i
do i need to know in terms of you know
partnerships alliances maybe even
just selling products to others
i would say in general i always like
my first rule even for myself is follow
you follow your heart so follow your
heart i i'm trying to follow mine and
trying to
to understand what it tells me at times
um when it's not very clear
um this is the first um i know life
advice um
um i i think i think you'll be a great
candidate for any business development
uh position because you're such a people
person
thank you already and you have no
problem in just
interacting with just about anybody in
any level
any so you have everything you need you
just need the content
to discuss about which is like for me
it's like
today tomorrow i don't know or yesterday
it was something else
but it's the same thing so you already
have everything you
you need you're you're perfect if you if
you're looking for something let me know
wonderful thank you thank you very much
tali before we leave i have to ask you
the most important question my favorite
question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself or that any of your
clients would use to describe tally
so i think the first thing that comes to
mind is kind of what i
said throughout this session i'm a
people person so really
loving people and just you know i'm
really
grateful to be able to do that every day
um for many hours every day um
a second thing um what can it be
oh so i i'm a constant learner i always
learn new things
and growth and learning i i study
quantum physics
and consciousness and brain science and
i just love learning new things not
not even related to my work everything
becomes related at the end by the way
everything is getting connected
but you just i always like i run every
day i always listen to audio books or
podcasts or something
or when even when i take a shower i'm
just having something what they're
always
what's your your favorite audiobook that
you read recently
um i hit a hit refresh by satya nadella
it's kind of a biography which was very
good and it was referencing
to growth mindset by the way speaking
about growth it was he was referencing
some a stanford uh
professor who wrote the book uh mindset
and he really changed the entire culture
in microsoft
uh around this uh
two great books that i've read recently
and
wonderful wait and i mean the power of
now if you like spirituality
definitely i and i need the third word
so i have people person i have constant
learners
i i would say i'm driven so i'm involved
in so many things i just drive things
and
my husband calls me my engine i'm his
engine so
i just like everything that you know i
love if it's work
driving business driving sales um
helping uh j ventures in in the fund or
anything else i'm involved just driving
things forward i'm very task oriented to
the degree then i'm trying to relax a
little bit
so so yeah so i would say those are
the main three things thank you very
very much and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you bye
bye